my advice as far as like when it comes
to whatever it is you want to write or
material you want to find
or a story you want to tell or you want
to do
is what's a movie you want to see
if you just truly love cinema with
enough passion
and you really love it then you can't
help but make a good movie
what's the movie that we have never seen
because you haven't made it and make
that movie
[Music]
i have i've gone i i do it differently
than i've done it before uh
i used to write all night that was kind
of my thing or i'd go and during the
daytime i'd write in restaurants or
something like that
and uh and just kind of being up all
night was kind of part of it
and then stopping for a while and
listening to music and that was all part
of it
then somewhere around in glorious
bastards i um
started writing during the day and i
would write on my uh
i have a balcony outside of my um
uh that has a place for a table and
stuff and it looks up to the i live in
the hollywood hills it looks up into the
greenery there it looks really nice and
it's uh it's
really pleasant out there and i can play
music and stuff it's so cool
and so anyway uh uh so like say i start
uh i started writing
like say around you know 10 10 30 11
something like that
and then i write till about uh you know
five six or seven something like that
but around around that time around five
or six i'm i'm gonna stop for the day
and what i do is i i stop for the day
and then after a little bit of time of
unwinding i go into my pool
and i keep it all nice and warm there
and everything and so i just kind of
hang out in the pool
and if i'm not done with something
i think okay um what do i want to do
what how how do i want to go further
with this
uh now that i've written the first pass
on it what do i think about it how can i
make it better
is there another element i can bring
into it did i uh do
add too much to yeah and whatever i'm
just uh looking at it critically
and maybe i come up with some neat ideas
and then i get out of the pool and i
make notes
on those neat ideas that i came up with
like thinking meditating about it
it actually is meditating um and then
that's my work
tomorrow when i get up all right or if i
finished a scene
okay boom boom that's done now that part
of the story is done
now i go in the pool and go okay what
happens next what's the next thing
and then i usually come up with a pretty
good idea and then i make my notes and
then that's the next day's work
and that was never really the way i did
it and that has come
exclusively the way i did in glorious
pastors and django
and this and it it it truly
brings a lot of joy to my life it's a
really really
lovely lovely way to work that makes me
feel really happy and the thing is
i know as a viewer the minute i start
getting confused
i check out of the movie emotionally i'm
confused
yeah if when i'm watching a movie and
all of a sudden something starts
happening where all of a sudden the
story line and everything is i it gets
confusing i don't know where i'm at
when i'm watching it my you know you i
think an audience has like this
you know like almost like an umbilical
cord to the to the screen
and it gets severed when when confusion
comes and therefore you lose them
exactly and the thing is most of the
time when you get confused when i get
confused and that's severed it's
basically because i'm not supposed to be
confused
all right that's like it's a mistake all
right um
however if you get confu there's no
problem with being
momentarily confused if you feel you're
in good hands
all right and i don't think my movie and
and disagree if you
please is that i don't think pulp
fiction for all of its goings in and
yeah around how it goes in this big
circle i don't think it's hard to watch
at all
you have to watch it i i ask for you to
watch it you can't like put this on
video and like do the new york times
crossword puzzle
and watch the movie that's right all
right i'll ask you put
everything down and watch it give me two
hours and whatever it is ten minutes
exactly and then once you do that
then you know you can follow it it's
it's easy to follow it was almost via
patti chai esky that i actually realized
that i actually
uh was not was a pretty good writer or
maybe want to
think about exploring this a little bit
because how i actually kind of
discovered writing dialogue
is i used to be uh be an actor and i'd
be in acting classes
and um and so part of your thing in
acting classes to drum up scenes to do
and i always wanted to do scenes from
movies and stuff
and then i didn't have access to any
scripts or anything like that so i would
like go and watch a movie
and then i could remember i had good
memories i'd remember the scene so i'd
go home and write the scene down and
whenever i didn't remember i would just
fill in the blanks myself
well little by little i would just start
filling in more blanks and more blanks
and just kind of
go off and do my own things and add to
the scenes that was me
first my first attempt at writing
dialogue with stuff like that
and i had forgotten i was doing a scene
with from marty
uh petty chairs marty in class and i was
later i was talking to uh the guy did
the scene with he goes um
i mentioned what i just mentioned he
goes you're you're as good as petty
chaieski
what are you talking about remember when
we did marty and all of a sudden there's
this monologue about the fountain
yeah that's not in marty that's you
i actually you gave me your handwritten
version i actually have marty at home
and i go there's
this there's no fountain there's a
monologue about a fountain in this scene
but it fit in perfect with the scene and
it was like what
it's just as good as the patty chayeski
stuff and it was literally it was his
name was ron coleman ronnie coleman and
um
when he said that it was like the first
dang little it was a little tiny dinner
bell you know little you know like the
one around the side of a table ding ding
ding
all right it was the first little ring
that was like maybe i should pay
attention to this maybe i should explore
this a little bit more
and so i thought the idea within the
case of pulp fiction that would be kind
of cool is to take three separate
stories and and and make them be the
oldest stories in the book
you know whether it be uh vincent's
character
the the hoodlum has to go out with the
boss's lady but don't touch her
and there's a whole history of people
who have touched her what happens well
we've seen that
before resilient times all right um and
um
in the case of uh the bruce willis story
that's that's the boxers supposed to
throw the fight and he doesn't and now
the mob's after him we've seen that
story a million times before
and one of the things i thought about
like the third story uh
was basically kind of the beginning of
at the time of almost every joel silver
movie which would start off with like a
couple of hit man showing up boom boom
all right you want to win just something
witness this and then they shoot the guy
and then they cut dornal swishing or
you're walking through the
forest and eventually he's gonna meet
those guys and so i thought well what
happens if we
hung out with them all night long
all day long all right after they've
killed the guy what happens with the
rest of their day
and so it was the idea of taking these
these chestnuts and putting them
together
and then actually having the characters
kind of intertwine and it all kind of
takes place in one
one city and it's an environment that
they all live in
and the characters kind of know each
other but you don't know that for a
while and i was just kind of
hanging out with them for those two days
your heroes are always anti-heroes
they're almost always villains
yeah i mean your your heroes are always
so it's not dark exactly because they're
kind of weirdly light villains i mean in
terms of their
happiness with villainy but they're
never
you know i mean again and again and
again you wouldn't call them
classic heroes i mean in the sense of
the heroic leading man like frederick
zoller yeah yeah yeah i mean is that
something that you think about when
you're writing i actually really
try to um have
morality not even be an issue at all
all right when it comes to my character
it's so interesting i mean
you know i don't want that to have any
play whatsoever i
that would be me commenting on them
right that is me sticking my big nose
into their lives and then their
philosophies i let them be who they are
and you know my biggest feeling is you
know i i just
i just want the same rights that a
novelist has i mean like we lived
through the 80s we're like [ __ ] every
hollywood movie
everyone had to be likable and everybody
had to be understandable
and uh and the test scores were like oh
we didn't like him so we got to change
every goddamn thing
you know and um i didn't make movies at
that time but i was watching them and
i'm not gonna make that crap
and um and i just want the same freedom
that a novelist has i mean you can make
a novel you write a novel about a
bastard but it can be totally
interesting
my advice as far as like when it comes
to whatever it is you want to write or
material you want to find or a story you
want to tell or you want to do
is what's a movie you want to see
what is the movie that's some you know
it's you know uh
uh what is it you want to contribute
all right uh and and and make it maybe
just even
slightly a little less about you
yourself i'm assuming most you guys
haven't made a feature yet
all right so but there's a lot of
features that have been made before you
there's a whole lot of movies you could
see a whole lot of movies you could
watch
without you what's the movie
that we have never seen because you
haven't made it
and make that movie make the movie
that it's the reason why you're gonna be
doing it
all right the truth of the matter is
good bad or indifferent reservoir dogs
didn't really exist before
i did it heist films had been made
and you know i there's a whole story
about this hong kong movie
city on fire if you've ever seen city on
fire it's very very different from my
movie
the section that they say i took i did
take from it all right absolutely i took
from it
all right but it's a very different
movie they actually talk to the director
ringo lam he goes wow
tarantino took the last 10 minutes of my
movie made an entire movie about it
well that's a [ __ ] different movie
that's very very different but the point
being though is what i had to say in my
kind of idea of crime films and my
idea of dialogue you know there was
barry levinson and tin men and there was
good fellas and there was all kinds
there's the david mamet stuff
all that stuff existed that that was
sort of like
reservoir dogs but it wasn't reservoir
dogs it didn't have this aesthetic that
i
that i'd been having you know because
the thing is i wasn't being you know
the movies that were collecting in my
head
for all the movies i saw i never saw
them i saw a flash of them
i saw a movie that would have a scene
that would be the aesthetic that i was
looking for or they would play a song in
a movie and that would be the kind of
song that i would use and it would have
the kind of feeling
that i'd want a song to have in one of
my movies
uh or a character would be the kind of
character that i wanted to do a movie
about not all the other characters just
one
character you know but usually like i
said it was a scene
it was uh a mood for only a little bit
or a section of the movie but it was
never the whole enchilada it was never
that aesthetic that was in my head was
never
just there i mean if it was just there
if
two or three other people were doing it
i might have been a filmmaker because i
didn't need to get it out of my head
and one of the director goes to have you
done your subtext work
no what's that ah you see you think
because you wrote it you know everything
but you don't know everything
you've done the writer work you haven't
done the director work you need to do
your subtext work
so he's describing this whole thing to
me and i was you know still pretty young
at the time
you know and i was like oh wow is that
really what a director does
wow really tell me about it and so
they're telling the whole thing
and i was actually really kind of
excited to go often and give this a shot
so i took to me what i thought was
like the most obvious scene you could
possibly take
i took mr white bringing mr orange
into the warehouse all by themselves mr
orange because he's a cop
is saying plea and he's dying please
please please
take me to the hospital mr white because
he doesn't know he's a cop he's like no
no no i can't take you to the hospital
i can just hang in there
so i
i could ask anybody in this theater here
what does that scene mean if you've seen
the movie
and you could tell me but when you
actually start putting
pen to paper comes a different thing it
actually a lot of stuff opened up that i
hadn't thought about before
because subtext is getting beyond what's
the obvious there and
so i wrote down what does mr white want
from the scene
more than anything else in the world
what's miss orange one from the scene
more than anything else in this world
and what do i as the filmmaker
want the audience to take away from the
scene more than anything else in the
world
and just even writing the obvious [ __ ]
about
mr orange is dying and he wants to be
taken to a hospital
all of a sudden the more i wrote the
more i realized
that the movie was the father-son story
and that mr white was functioning as mr
orange father
at that moment and mr orange was
functioning as a son but he was a son
who betrayed his father
but his father doesn't know about the
betrayal and he's trying to hide it from
him as long as he can because
the guilt is really starting to hit him
yet
mr white has faith in joe cabot
lawrence turner who is his metaphorical
father
in this situation and what does he keep
saying they're looking
just don't worry about it wait for joe
to get here
when joe gets here you're all going to
be fine it's all
going to be fine and what happens when
joe gets there
he kills mr orange and then actually mr
white has to choose between his father
his spiritual fa
his metaphorical father and his
metaphorical son and naturally he
chooses his metaphorical son
and he's wrong but he's wrong for all
the right reasons
that was pretty heavy that's fascinating
and
that was pretty heavy and me as a
student at sundance
is in my little bungalow in the snow
and i'm writing all that and i was like
wow that's really cool that that's
that's deep there's a lot of there there
well i'm glad to know my work has such
depth
i'm glad to know that the roots extend
that far deep but i never want to know
about those roots again
because i know they're there and i don't
want to tell a father-son story i want
to tell my gangster story i want to tell
my high story the father-son story will
take care of itself the father-son story
is for everybody else who invest in it
and the father-son story is there
because it is
deeper than just a robbery but
me i want to deal with the robbery
and let the other guy who's doing the
writing who knows about the roots
deal with the roots unbelievable
most of the characters in the movie are
given choices to make
and they make the choices that they make
and they pay
and they pay the price or the
consequences or they live to tell the
tale
uh because of those choices and we
actually see it happen
all three different times in the movie
and uh but actually but it's
it's funny though if you if you just
take that
for what it is if you just look at the
case of john travolta and sam jackson it
would suggest
well okay sam jackson made the good
choice made the right choice unless he
prospers and
john travolta pays no attention to it
and thus we know he dies
but you have to but you have to think
about bruce willis choice
that happens in this movie because he
actually makes two choices one he makes
it a choice
to do a very an honorable thing you know
he actually makes the deal with
marcellus wallace
to throw the fight he doesn't have to
marcellus doesn't say
throw the fighter you're dead he makes
it for money
and he takes the money and he screws
marcelo's woman um
but he actually ends up living to tell
the tale because he actually does make a
moral choice later when he goes back to
save marcellus
but he's still starting from a very bad
place and he actually ends up prospering
you know for it but again he does make
him you know he does make a moral choice
that he doesn't have to
um but if he had now if he had left
that's
i'm just thinking about it now if he had
left the pawn shop and just
let marcellus be buggered he just left
that
you know would he still get out of town
you know
with uh with fabian would he still make
it to tennessee would he still have all
the money and everything like that
now he'd be looking over his shoulder
now right now he's not looking over his
shoulder because he did the moral thing
he actually got away with it when i
write a character
that doesn't have a lot that doesn't say
a lot doesn't get it across a lot in
uh in dialogue and doesn't have that
many story beats
in order or this giant you know the
other giant reveals are happening
uh i tend to write those characters more
prose like
i tend to write them a little bit more
like a novel all right uh
uh you know and i'm i'm putting a lot of
stuff in there that you guys the
audience is never gonna see and you're
never supposed to see it
all right but it's it's there for the
reader
you know i i want the person who's
reading the script to have a good time
and to be engaged in the story and
there's stuff for the reader that's
meant for them
and and and it's not meant for you and
there's uh uh
and uh but it's also it's meant for the
actor
and so it gives the actor like a sense
of who this guy is
and more than most other scripts like i
said
i did a lot of exploring with this by
writing stuff that
didn't doesn't even quite make the
script like just to give you an idea um
like i wrote a whole prose chapter
of exactly what happened on the boat
with uh i written like like the first
chapter of a book all right it was
called misadventure
[Music]
[Laughter]
and there you find out exactly what
happened i'm not telling you guys all
right but
brad knows you know uh um and i you know
and it was all it was all it's all it
was all done as it was all done as pros
and it was like a little chapter of a
book and he got a real sense of it all
right in the case of uh
describing rick dalton's career
for example and like the career the his
filmography
his situation that he had the situation
that he got to the situation he has now
i wrote i wrote that as not just like a
chapter in a book i wrote it like a
chapter of a film book
like a film book about rick dalton it
was called the man who would be mcqueen
[Laughter]
and uh and frankly to tell you the truth
it was it was when leo read that
is what finally pushed him over the edge
to say yes
you know uh uh to the character because
then he had a sense of it and it was
literally written as if like you know
uh like tim lucas in a video watchdog
has written like a chapter on the career
of rick dalton
you don't have to know how to make a
movie if you truly
love cinema with all your heart
and with enough passion you can't
help but make a good movie you don't
have to go to school
you don't have to know a lens you know a
40 and a 50 and a
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] crossing the line
none of that shit's important
if you just truly love cinema with
enough passion
and you really love it then you can't
help but make a good movie
hi everybody thank you so much for
watching
we really dug deep to find you only the
most valuable screenwriting piece of
advice
from quentin tarantino and we found a
lot of hidden gems
from this screenwriting mastermind so we
made another video with an additional 5
screenwriting tips from quentin
tarantino
for our patreon supporters the link to
our patreon page
is in the description below let us know
in the comments from what screenwriter
or film
you want to learn screenwriting lessons
in our future videos
keep writing and see you in the next
video